upskilling is extremely essential for
any working professional nowadays
especially in the ever-changing
landscape of Technology the right skills
can help you grow as a professional and
boost your confidence after completing
the professional certificate program in
data analytics from Simply learn in
partnership with Purdue University my
career took a significant turn
I was able to change my career domain
from teaching kids to providing
Supportive Services to adults at the
Department of Rehabilitation in San
Francisco I was also offered the
director of Africa position at gatherers
and I have been featured in Black
entrepreneurial magazine in which was a
great honor hi my name is Rose Ashford
and I am the civil servant currently
supporting the Department of
Rehabilitation in San Francisco
California and I'm also the director of
Africa at gather purse which is a
rapidly growing virtual platform that
brings the metaverse and emerging
Technologies together into a clear
human-centered view before completing
the course I was a volunteer there my
upscaling open new doors for me I have
three master's degrees and during the
pandemic I saw the world shift towards
immersive virtual world that is
facilitated by metaverse after
researching a lot I decided to go for
the data analytics program that simply
learned and the courses offered were the
perfect stepping stone for me I even
gained a lot of great professional
contacts through the program we all
support each other in our endeavors and
connect online
the experience that I have would simply
learn was amazing The Faculty was very
encouraging
even though some of the content and
Concepts were intimidating for me they
made sure that I felt confident enough
to understand and finish the course
modules and the projects the projects
were based on real life scenarios and I
feel that they were key in helping me
understand all kinds
I even learn our coding through this
course which was a first for me and I'm
really proud of it I was pursuing my
third master's degree while taking this
course and with the help of all the
technical new knowledge that I gained
during the course I was able to write my
paper very effectively I am also taking
interviews from Young students in Africa
online which I really enjoy and I want
to continue to empower kids I see myself
spreading the word and making Tech less
intimidating for others and I'm excited
about my future and I encourage all
professionals to consider upskilling